if you add up the iqs of your three best  friends and of your partner's three best  friends which group is smarter  headphones on this is a no-brainer okay  all right lay it on all right so i have  a friend that still eats his boogers  for fun  this is for real yes  and he's in his 40s he cups his farts  and he'll and dinner right he's never  read a book right she has a friend that  works for nasa  okay i only have one friend that's the  guy the fart guy right  she's got real brains in her side  so it's definitely her friends not mom  nice  let's  it's the easiest game i've ever played  oh my god  he has friends that still light their  farts on fire  [Applause]